dès 2009 plusieurs reportages révèle
collusion et corruption dans le monde
municipal
l'escouade marteau de la escure réussi
en février 2011
une première opération avec
l'arrestation de l'entrepreneur lino
zambito et la mairesse de boisbriand
sylvie st-jean
c'est l'upac nouvellement créée qui
prendra le relais pour enquêter sur tous
ces scandales avec à sa tête un policier
de carrière robert lafrenière les succès
se multiplient l'opération gravier frat
mascouche le maire richard marcotte et
l'entrepreneur tony accurso sont arrêtés
qu'est ce que vous avez à dire encore et
alex guillaume deux mois suivants l'ex
numéro deux de la ville de montréal
frank zampino était épinglé dans le
scandale du faubourg contrecoeur et à
partir de maintenant je vais consacrer
l'énergie
j'ai pris ma défense à prouver mon
innocence le plus gros coup de filet et
l'arrestation de l'ancien maire de laval
gilles vaillancourt
avec trente six autres personnes les
mois passent et les toiles de l'upac
brille toujours on arrête pierre duhaime
l'ex pdg de snc lavalin arthur et pamela
porteur pour le scandale du csm
michael applebaum le maire de montréal
par intérim
les personnes qui font l'objet
d'accusations criminelles en 2016 en
fait une première arrestation dans
l'univers politique provinciale nathalie
normandeau
cette opération donne confiance au
public l'upac est capable d'enquêter sur
autre chose que les magouilles dans le
monde municipal
mais en 2018 tony accurso est acquitté à
joliette
les accusés du faubourg contrecoeur ou
si peu de temps après dans une tentative
d'intimidation sobre et ce dans le
député guy ouellette arrêté sans jamais
être accusé de quoi que ce soit voilée
mandat de perquisition contre lui cassé
par un tribunal
après tous ces revers le commissaire
robert lafrenière dont le mandat venait
d'être renouvelé
kit l'upac sans explication le 1er
octobre 2018
entre-temps l'upac est devenu un corps
de police
un comité de surveillance a été mise en
place en 2018
mais rien n'y fait les revers 7 nuls le
dpcp retire les accusations les plus
graves entre nathalie normandeau et marc
yvan côté
frank zampino obtient un arrêt des
procédures plusieurs enquêtes piétinent
notamment celle sur le financement
illégal au parti libéral du québec le
mandat de frédérick gaudreau s'annonce
pleine défi ici isabelle richer radio
canada montréal